It’s the holiday season.
Outside, it’s cold and there's snow blanketing
the ground.
But inside, you’re warm, and gathered around
the light of a roaring fireplace and a glowing
Christmas tree.
This is what Christmas is all about – warmth,
joy, and togetherness.
But just because you’re comfortable doesn’t
mean you’re safe.
You were so busy opening presents and stuffing
yourself at dinner that you didn’t notice
the face pressed up against the window.
That long, gaunt face, with the staring eyes,
the wide mouth full of yellow teeth, and the
scraggly, white beard.
You don’t know it yet, but within a few
days, you’ll be dead.
You might be able to avert this horrible fate,
if only you knew what exactly you were dealing
with: SCP – 4666, also known as The Yule
Man.
A Keter-Class Christmas monster so violent,
sadistic, and terrifying, he makes Krampus
look like jolly Saint Nick.
And this year, just like every other, he’s
planning on being very, very naughty.
The SCP Foundation began cataloguing the Yule
Man in 1974 after a string of violent and
eerily similar home invasions during the holiday
season, but they have reason to believe that
this entity has been around for a whole lot
longer.
Over 2000 years in fact.
Stories that describe what look to be Yule
Man massacres date as far back as the First
Century BC in Scandinavia, and there have
been reports of similar clusters of events
happening around the same time every year
since.
This monster is prolific, and may have one
of the highest body counts of any creature
under observation by the Foundation.
The Yule Man’s trail of destruction became
clearer in the eighteenth century, as accounts
of the carnage it leaves became more detailed.
Later still, authorities even managed to find
physical evidence like the Yule Man’s fingerprints
– which are similar to human fingerprints,
but display a distinct double-whorl pattern
not seen in human fingerprints.
Much about the anomalous nature of the Yule
Man is still unknown though, and the Foundation
has yet to discover an effective way to contain
it.
Their only hope is intercepting it before
it can get its long, gnarled fingers on its
intended prey.
Maybe you’re feeling worried, or that you’re
being watched.
You have a good reason to be afraid, because
during his yearly active period – the twelve
days between December 21st and January 2nd
– he’s always searching for prey.
Nowhere is safe, because while it was initially
believed that he only appeared to those who
lived north of 40 degrees latitude, it’s
now believed that much like Santa Claus, the
Yule Man operates worldwide.
Anyone could be in his sights right now, blissfully
unaware of the nightmare coming down the tracks
towards them.
Thankfully, the SCP Foundation, through analysis
of these attacks which are known as Weissnacht
Events, they’ve been able to find certain
patterns.
But first, what does the creature known as
The Yule Man even look like?
Much like SCP – 096, the Yule Man is a long
and lanky humanoid standing about two meters
tall, who resembles an emaciated human of
European descent, and never wears any clothes
or other coverings despite the frigid temperatures
he operates in.
You might be sad if you’re spending Christmas
alone, but it at least guarantees you safety
from the Yule Man, as he only appears at the
homes of families with a child under the age
of eight present.
He also seems to favor isolated and rural
locations, and Weissnacht Events only occur
when there’s a healthy covering of snow
on the ground during the event – hence the
name which means “White Night” in English.
It’s also vital that you recognize the three
distinct stages of a Weissnacht Event, too,
or you won’t be seeing much of the New Year.
The first stage occurs during the space of
a week.
Children in the home might start to seem worried
or afraid.
They might tell you that they see something
strange in the distance.
The figure of a man they don’t recognize,
standing just far enough away that you can’t
fully make him out, except that he’s really
tall.
Of course, you probably won’t see anything,
and your instinct will be to tell them there’s
nothing to be afraid of.
Even when they tell you, through tears, that
there’s a man pressing his face up against
their bedroom window at night.
But they are right to be afraid, and you should
be, too.
Already at this point, your only hope is to
try and spread the word as soon as possible:
Report the incident to the local police, write
about it on Facebook, tweet about it.
Whatever it takes.
The SCP Foundation has operatives trawling
the internet and monitoring police reports
constantly during this period, especially
for reports of mysterious men in the snow
watching homes from a distance.
Getting the Foundation’s attention is your
best hope of stopping this thing.
And if you don’t?
Next comes stage two, taking place between
nights eight and eleven of the active period.
No longer will the Yule Man just be lurking
on the periphery.
Now he’s getting closer.
You’ll start to hear strange noises in your
attic or on the roof, noises that sound almost
like footsteps.
That’s crazy, you think, it’s probably
just an animal.
But then, the smell starts.
An awful, rotten stench that fills the house,
but no matter how hard you look, you can’t
find the source.
Finally, on the last night of December, you
tell yourself that you’ll take this matter
to the police.
But of course, it’s already too late.
The Yule Man is here for the twelfth night.
The Weissnacht is finally upon you.
At this point, one of two scenarios will happen.
In the first, you and your entire family will
be tortured and murdered, except the youngest
child, who the Yule Man will kidnap.
The SCP Foundation keeps files on a number
of notable instances of this kind of Weissnacht,
and the details are truly gruesome.
Reports of incidents have involved crucifixion,
the removal of tongues, burning, dismemberment,
post mortem bitemarks, and decapitation.
In all instances though, the entire family
was killed except the youngest child, who
simply disappeared.
The Yule Man is a merciless and sadistic beast.
You’re now probably wondering: If that’s
the first of two Weissnacht possibilities,
what’s the second?
In the second, if you’re tremendously lucky,
you and your family will survive – but that
doesn’t mean you won’t face a grisly experience.
In this scenario, which occurs during about
fifteen percent of Weissnacht Events, you’ll
hear footsteps throughout the night, but thankfully,
you wake up alive.
And when you do so, there are gifts waiting
for you.
The problem is, all these gifts are made out
of human body parts.
For example, in 1976 in Canada, one family
received the gift of a ball made from a severed
human head wrapped in skin.
In Kazakhstan in 1903, a family received a
flute made from a hollowed out human femur.
And in the Netherlands in 2003, a family received
a wooden hairbrush, covered in human teeth
ranging from 400 years old to a mere few days.
These gruesome gifts are referred to as SCP
– 4666 – A, and it was one of these gifts
that gave us the best insight yet available
into the true nature of the Yule Man.
Several gifts were dropped off at a family's
residence in Hoonah, Alaska, in 2018, but
most notable among them was the horrific SCP-4666-A-0960
– a life-sized doll made from a human body,
with its eyes removed and mouth sewn shut.
Worst of all though, was that the girl was
still alive.
The family who received this twisted gift
was given amnestics by the Foundation, and
the living doll was taken for medical treatment.
Before succumbing to her extensive injuries,
the girl was able to deliver some insights
into what exactly happened to the children
who were abducted during Weissnacht Events.
The children taken by the Yule Man are forced
into a large sack that seems much bigger on
the inside than it appears as he makes his
rounds, travelling from house to house, murdering
and kidnapping.
His victims are taken to a kind of underground
grotto and workshop filled with bones, like
a twisted Santa’s workshop, where they’re
forced to make toys out of the bodies of their
fellow victims.
During this time, the Yule Man will continue
to torture and torment his victims.
He’ll even take some of them away to cook
and eat whenever he feels like it.
When asked how she was turned into this human
doll, the girl told Foundation personnel that
her fellow victims were forced to turn her
into this by the Yule Man when she became
too weak to continue making toys herself.
Her chilling last words were, “When you
can’t make the toys, you become the toys.”
So if strange things happen to you and your
family between the 21st of December and the
1st of January, don’t ignore it.
After all, you never know who’s watching.
But if it is the Yule Man’s grinning face
pressed up against your window, it may already
be too late.
Happy Holidays…
Now go check out “SCP – 4000 – Taboo”
and “SCP – 2317 – The Devourer of Worlds”
for more!